hello fans of me
I'm Greg hello not fan of me putting
paper glasses
amber placer - her name on YouTube find
those awesome videos on her channel
subscribe to it a lot of fun movie talk
hey amber say one thing we were talking
about is how you saw John wick -
recently had its premiere right I did
yeah I got to visit with my friend
liza monet and she got to cover the red
carpet I got to be suplex woman oh no
the red carpet oh that's great and my
favorite sighting was actually
keegan-michael key key key Michael key
well amber a man named rage huh I know a
thing or two about rage you're in touch
with yours
um I think it's important to be in touch
with your rage at any given moment today
this is going to go so corridors the
channel called nerf John wick you might
have heard of it - making the round I
think I have an idea for what could be
like let's watch it
ah what it does is gonna look really
cool oh cool I love only love this down
to sex mom
yeah hitting them yeah burn on and
everything
oh here we go look I gotta go Rico I
[Music]
[Music]
said oh my god
Wow it's really good
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ah-ha-ho the [ __ ] people I hope they
give another one that was so cool
actually had a moment
halfway to die was like I will never
create anything this meaningful it's so
good it was so good this is the ultimate
example of like I want to get together
with my friends it really fun and funny
and have it be good right actually one
this is so funny because they did the
John wick choreography of the gunplay as
if it was actual guns they also took
time to implement specific nerf moments
yes like peek at is a nerf go boy yeah
and they're full of sick city which
shows it is raining I loved it I loved
it that was so that was so funny and is
it when were you sucking in the neck or
now you go yeah I think even it was the
head I think it was I'm not sure I want
to go do it yeah I think yeah I find
that one moment see the choreography
because you can't help we go this still
looks cool even though it's still silly
at the same time because nerve but but I
thought it was like a fun little latex I
mean we're not twelve-year-old boys but
this is like a twelve-year-old boys
dream right I mean I think we could play
this game today yeah I was like why
don't I was like why don't I have a
nurse why don't I have a single nerve
kinda one single nurse gun for instances
like this just so we didn't lose them my
cat you know they're gonna like tear up
a bullet I'm just really disappointed
that I didn't think of this video idea
but all I can think is how brilliant it
is and I'm just so sad so I didn't make
it my
yeah so good shot really cool too was
some who did this man credit Miller a DP
I can hire it was amazing
what about corridor channel yeah I love
this one hundred fifty hundred demons
Illya does it just get more users and if
you watch chapter two of John wick kids
like [ __ ] they're aware inhabited
yeah I get it because John way to things
is ridiculous new high Sam and Nico and
their skillful skillful skillful crew
beautiful skillful cruel so I feel s
that's in your heart thank you little
crew beautiful get it that K yo couple
children this is why we never created
nerf John wick how we put together a
skillful group we can't even say the
damn word is that was amazing oh my god
I mean what Morgan you really say others
like what do you want to do more see
John wick or buying your gun after
watching it I want to I want to play
this game with a bunch of friends right
if they built an event like at comic-con
or something and these guys and you
could like pay admission to go I would
pay there should be like money bazillion
dollar so it's gonna be a place where
you can battling laser tag with nerf gun
right I think there has to be a point I
also I was just like to say that I have
to have to thought that we should play
more laser tag station life I really
just having the park how do you do that
with like anti they put an event
together you don't know that yeah no
nope right right when the Sun comes up
in a sign I never asked that question
no I only played at least act like
indoors like a few times
well it's amazing from this anyway all
right guys you got subscriber corridor
I'm going to check out way more of their
videos totally crying I had some kind of
an awesome video seriously nerfed y'all
wick watch this I'm gonna watch some
shows the people get is nerf overwatch
they have a whole yeah have a whole
bunch of nerve change their channel to
just nerve parody nervous yeah no one
will do better than that
that is amazing so go check them out
immediately hey you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you should
what if you're here with that belt and
our blaster
yeah yeah the amber Platzer Channel yes
that's not what the URL is this is I
need to make it that and even make it
that because I think I want to type all
that animal at the time an amber
classroom too luckily I'm the only amber
plaster on YouTube because I have a
weird last name so I'm very fortunate
that I'm covering the only one I'm just
off on afterbuzz TV please go find her
there and shout out to rage for being
the number one request sir
yeah rage you did it you did it without
hurting anyone we're proud of you I mean
you might have emotionally hurt some
people because rage can do that but you
know physically you have so good day on
you go